foreign
[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity an IRS whistleblower has
reluctantly come forward with damning
allegations about the doj's hunter Biden
case I don't want to do any of this he
said still he's coming forward because
it's the right thing to do and just like
that the media mob no longer reveres
whistleblowers in fact they're now
trying to bury this story completely
watch there is something personal that's
affecting you your son while there's no
ties to you could be charged by your
Department of Justice how will that
impact your presidency
first of all my son's done nothing wrong
I trust him I have faith in him and it
impacts my presidency by making me feel
proud of you
but thanks to House Republicans The
Whistleblower will be heard his legal
team says he spoke to bipartisan
staffers from the Ways and Means
Committee for six hours today and here
now with more is Fox News contributor
Jonathan Turley uh Jonathan thank you
there's there's a lot that's very
troubling about this case but he did
come forward he did do an interview and
it was fascinating to hear what he said
what's your take on what's going on here
well this is seismic you have someone
who is a long serving IRS
agent someone who is not a political
appointee who's coming forward and
saying look I've had enough that is he
said that when he was in this position
what he saw with the hunter Biden
investigation he had never seen with any
other case and he said time and time
again
decisions were made that uniformly
benefited Hunter Biden that's troubling
and it gets even more troubling when he
identifies the source of interference
with the investigation and that is the
justice department itself he says it was
the justice department uh that caused
much of these concerns but also
ultimately it was the justice department
that pooled the entire IRS team off the
case now that's worthy of Investigation
we have now an expanding investing into
the influence peddling of the Biden
family the house just released
information showing a Labyrinth of
accounts and corporations used to
transfer Millions to Biden family
members we now have heard from this
whistleblower that possibly the Biden
Administration itself has been taking
steps that benefit the president's son
that should be troubling to everyone
yeah but the lack of intellectual
curiosity by the media the fourth estate
is just not there I find it interesting
that the White House makes the case that
they will not comment on this but in a
softball interview the President says my
son's done nothing wrong signaling to
the Department of Justice that my son
has done nothing wrong attorney general
Garland said there would be no
interference but you have a
whistleblower who comes across his
highly credible
going on camera and now we'll be going
before Congress and testifying that they
did suppress him that they did dismantle
his team and that they did put pressure
on him and boy look how fast they went
after George Santos they didn't have any
trouble coming up with indictments on
him but hunter Biden it's been years
right that's right
yeah this would explain why it's taken
so long because this whistleblower says
they intentionally slow walked the
investigation of the president's son and
the response the Democrats to
whistleblowers is really troubling I've
represented whistleblowers and these are
are people who've come forward at Great
risk including this individual but the
Democrats have had a scorched Earth
campaign targeting whistleblowers the
hearing in which they attacked these FBI
whistleblowers was breathtaking they've
attacked journalists who've come forward
just to highlight a censorship program
they they questioned whether they were
real journalists the ranking member of
that subcommittee suggested one of the
journalists should be arrested I mean
this is really turning into a sort of
mccarthy-like period And I think the
public doesn't support it the public
wants transparency they believe that
corruption is something that should be
investigated including influence
peddling and so I think this is going to
be a very difficult road to hope for the
Democrats when the public is very
unified saying that they want these
investigations to go forward
yeah and remember when the Attorney
General Garland sent that multi-page uh
warning to whistleblowers about better
make sure better better make sure you
check with your officers there at the
Department of Justice before you go see
Congress that was so fundamentally
totally wrong put that on the list of
other things that need to be rectified
Professor Turley thank you appreciate
you joining us hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else